[Musique]
Hélène buzetti José Legault Christian
Dufour bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir alors
c'est quand même inouï cette histoire
monsieur Trudeau
apparemment selon ce qu'on en sait ce
qu'on nous a raconté dit au président
Simpson ne vous mêlez pas des élections
canadiennes et tout ça et là aujourd'hui
on comprend que finalement il y a jamais
été passée moi l'expression briefée
là-dessus Hélène alors quand il dit au
président en Chine on va entendre deux
trois extraits aujourd'hui qu'on revient
tout de suite
par rapport à de l'ingérence dans notre
système électoral par rapport surtout à
l'idée de financer de nos candidats des
candidats pour les parties principaux je
n'ai jamais eu aucune information
là-dessus de mes services de
renseignement qui me tiennent à jour sur
tous ces enjeux là
ça devient inquiétant je disais si il
s'est rien passé pourquoi tu prends la
peine d'en parler à la deuxième personne
la plus puissante au monde
si le premier ministre du Canada
maintient sa position qui n'a jamais été
au courant là maintenant ce qu'on veut
savoir à partir de maintenant qu'est-ce
qu'il fait
pour faire la lumière là-dessus c'est
pas parce que Monsieur Trudeau dit j'en
ai jamais entendu parler qui s'est rien
passé
bon Hélène pour vous éclairer ma
lanterne s'il vous plaît qu'est-ce qu'on
en sait et qu'est-ce qu'il a dit au
président chinois puis pourquoi on pense
que ça au président chinois et je vous
écoute mais il faut faire la distinction
entre l'ingérence et le COS spécifique
d'ingérence qui a attiré tant notre
attention là depuis le reportage de
Global reportage qui disait là qui avait
11 candidats conservateurs et ou
libéraux qui avait été financé
clandestinement par des agents chinois
c'est ça que Monsieur Trudeau dit
n'avoir jamais su mais de manière
générale le gouvernement canadien
reconnaît qu'il y a de l'ingérence
étrangère dans notre processus électoral
mais à chaque élection celle de 2019 et
2021 celle pour lesquelles on a mis en
place des mécanismes de surveillance on
nous dit que cette ingérence n'est pas
suffisante au code significatif au point
d'interférer et de compromettre
l'intégrité des élections alors
maintenant qu'est-ce que Monsieur
Trudeau a dit précisément président
chinois je le sais pas plus que vous
Patrick mais de l'ingérence il y a
quelle nature on le sait pas moi je
m'étais roche surtout si effectivement
cette histoire des 11 est vrai comment
se fait-il que le premier ministre n'en
n'est pas été informé je trouve ça quand
même assez intéressant cette émission
José vous cette histoire là vous en êtes
tout dans votre analyse
mais je suis un peu perdu moi aussi là
donc évidemment comme le disait Hélène
on ne sait pas vraiment ce que Monsieur
Trudeau et le président chinois se sont
dit dans le plan des yeux
mais il reste que dans le compte-rendu
on en faisait état de cette
problématique là il a aujourd'hui le
premier ministre Canada nous dit que bon
c'est c'est il y a jamais une nouvelle
est-ce que ce serait
parce que évidemment il y a une
inquiétude à ne pas laisser flotter dans
l'air la possibilité qu'une puissance
étrangère aurait pu
s'ingérer dans le processus électoral
Canadien aurait pu même influer sur le
processus électoral canadien il y a
peut-être beaucoup de ça aussi
surtout avec ce qui se passe aux
États-Unis mais j'avoue que là on est un
petit peu en manque de clarté là ok bon
ben je vous recommande
votre patience Christian
si vous vouliez vous conclure sur la
chaîne vous êtes inspiré par notre
ministre l'environnement et et quand
même il dit ça a été décevant la cop27
en Egypte pour pour les émissions de gaz
inflexaire
je veux parler de l'environnement je
trouve que pour Monsieur Guilbault parce
que je trouve c'est pas très stimulant
prête pas très encourageant mon message
puis moi je trouve pas très clair pour
être fort moi je peux pas dire que je
suis comprends tout il me semble que
c'est quelqu'un qui a avalé quand même
beaucoup de couleurs monsieur Guilbaud
pour participer au pouvoir il y a une
noblesse là-dedans parce que c'était
quand même un militant
environnementaliste qui s'est fait
accusé en fait de laisser tomber ses
idéaux mais là je trouve qu'il faudrait
qu'il désespérément qu'il y ait un
succès clair quelconque moi je trouve
communiste là ça manque des expériment
parce que la crédibilité est en train de
se filocher et quand aux conférences
internationales je veux pas jouer à
l'expert là-dessus mais je trouve que le
problème c'est que ça déçoit très très
souvent parce que il y a beaucoup de
gens évidemment qui sont alarmés à bon
droit par la environnemental donc ils
veulent avoir des résultats plus clairs
il y a même un certain catastrophisme or
les résultats sont pas toujours si clair
que ça peut aussi on est dans une
bureaucratie internationale il faut être
réaliste c'est des beaux discours des
belles conférences faut garder notre
lucidité il y a quand même un gros
décalage anti-condi puisqu'on fait quand
les pays qui qui ont payé le prix là
pour le réchauffement climatique veulent
des indemnités je leur souhaite bonne
chance parce que c'est pas parce que un
premier ministre ou un président est
signé un papier que l'argent va suivre
nécessairement c'est ça que donc je
m'excuse un peu déprimé mon affaire la
question qu'on peut se poser puis juste
une question rhétorique là j'ai pas la
réponse mais y a-t-il une autre avenue
où il y avait 33000 participants Hélène
et José à cette conférence la cop27 mais
y a-t-il une autre avenue
si on veut parler de la planète on peut
pas être à 8 autour de la table non plus
Hélène
mais peut-être que 33000 c'est beaucoup
aussi
que ceci ok je vais retomber sur les
rails de notre prochain sujet qu'on
voulait aborder hier ça nous a frappé on
était plusieurs avec frappé par
l'absence de français dans le témoignage
du grand patron du SCRS David vino
Davido qui a étudié adversé de Montréal
donc il parle évidemment qui parle
français qui est francophone je vous
fais entendre un petit extrait de son
témoignage d'hier et on revient en
parler
alors José je commence avec vous il
aurait pu témoigner en français il
aurait pu témoigner en français le
commissaire rouleau les juge a dit vous
témoignez la langue que vous voulez tous
témoignent en anglais pourquoi
de toute évidence il faut déduire de ça
que l'anglais est probablement la langue
dominante de travail dans leur propre
environnement et donc tout le discours
tout le vocabulaire
et principalement en anglais ça veut pas
dire que Monsieur Vignon n'est pas
capable de s'exprimer parfaitement bien
en français mais c'est un problème qui
existe aussi depuis longtemps et qui
s'accentue dans la haute fonction
publique fédérale et on peut peut-être
revenir tout à l'heure si vous voulez
sur sur la dynamique de la Loi sur les
langues officielles mais pour moi c'est
c'est vraiment le reflet que le confort
est plus important en anglais qu'en
français Hélène oui je suis d'accord
avec ce que José vient de dire mais
j'ajouterai à ça que il y a aussi le
fait que dans cette salle la salle où se
déroule les audiences les avocats ne
sont pas tous bilingue plusieurs leçons
mais tous ne le sont pas et donc il y a
bien des intervenants qui qui voudraient
peut-être parler français mais que bon
on se dit je vais peut-être être un peu
ma traduction sera peut-être pas bonne
on va peut-être pas bien me comprendre
et donc je préfère le faire directement
dans la langue qui sera compris de tous
mais ça c'est quelque chose qu'on voit
tellement souvent à Ottawa le français
la place du français s'effrite peu à peu
et dans le témoignage de Monsieur vigno
il y a même eu un moment donné où
l'avocat un des avocats de la commission
lui a dit votre phrase n'est pas tout à
fait claire peut-être que c'est parce
que vous vous parlez en anglais c'est
pas votre langue voulez-vous le répéter
en français et cet avocat unilingue
anglophone insistait pour donner la
parole en français à me suivre et jamais
il n'a pas assez en français il y a
aussi le conseiller municipal Mathieu
Fleury qui a un moment donné oh lui
aussi fait sa comparution presque
exclusivement en anglais mais à un
moment donné il y a dit si vous me
permettez j'aimerais passer en français
parce que ce sont des termes techniques
puis je serai plus à l'aise et l'avocat
qui était à ce moment-là l'avocat des
camionneurs donc peut-être un peu
brutale c'est un peu moqué de lui en
disant quels sont les mots que vous ne
comprenez pas dans ma question très très
condescendants donc ça vous donne ça
vous donne l'idée de l'ambiance ça se
passe il y a de la traduction si comme
la Commission à l'époque il y a la
traduction les Anglais ne parle pas
français peuvent se mettre dans les
oreilles des trucs non oui absolument
très bien ok Christian première réaction
quelle tristesse que le honte c'est
vraiment terrible d'avoir des Canadiens
français de service c'est sûr que c'est
en fait c'est des Canadiens de français
de services en fait qui sont des
francophones au Québec je comprends plus
parce que parfaitement bilingue sont
habitués de vivre dans un environnement
francophone minoritaire mais quand ce
sont des Québécois francophones
d'origine qui viennent d'université
Laval qui témoigne publiquement il faut
le noter il a peut-être que ces gens-là
quand ils sont dans leur bureau ils
travaillent en anglais beaucoup je n'en
doute pas mais là il s'adressait au
public hier Patrice vous l'avez dit ça
vous ennuie dans votre émission parce
qu'on avait pas d'extrait en français
quel manque de respect pour le public
francophone ce sont des francophones
diplômés
la Loi sur les langues officielles
s'appliquent et tout le monde il y a le
ministre est-ce qu'on l'a le ministre ce
qu'on a le ministre on va on va écouter
monsieur Leblanc qui est allé témoigner
deviné dans quelle langue on écoute
ers
justement c'est que non seulement c'est
la langue dominante de travail l'anglais
dans la haute fonction publique dans le
monde politique etc mais si ce qu'on
nous renvoie en ce moment c'est une
image du réel et c'est sûr que cette
image là de la réalité elle fait mal
parce que parce que la Loi sur les
langues officielles a créé une certaine
illusion et là si on revient à Trudeau
pair on a compris à l'époque je sais pas
pourquoi que cette loi là était censée
promouvoir et faciliter l'extension du
bilingus mais individuel à travers le
Canada alors que c'est pas ça du tout la
logique de la Loi sur les langues
officielles c'est vraiment de de
favoriser ça pour vraiment réussir à
faire ça non plus mais de favoriser la
capacité d'obtenir des services dans sa
langue si on est francophone ou si on
est anglophones n'importe où à travers
le Canada ce qu'elle a dit tout à
l'heure sur la présence d'avocat qui ne
va pas nécessairement français
c'est ça le principe aussi d'efficacité
là ce sont pas nécessairement des
Canadiens français de service mais ils
sont aussi dans cette dans ce climat là
donc au Québec la connaissance du
français chez les anglophones de langue
d'usage anglaise confondues c'est
minimal c'est en bas de 10% alors ça
fait que aussi dans la fonction publique
vous avez peu d'anglophones qui ont une
connaissance suffisante français et qui
fait que par efficacité les francophones
vont tout simplement oui ça manque de
respect je suis d'accord avec toi
Christian mais en même temps c'est tout
ça est tout c'est une dynamique qui a
été enclenchée avec une illusion
très très rapidement
faut-il que les messages politiques
soient envoyés c'est plus un message
politique puis les seuls messages
politiques sont envoyés par Ottawa
actuellement c'est en faveur des
autochtones puis du multicultural
de francophones on parle de francophones
de souche c'est un gros manque de
jugement
anglais mais c'est un gros manque de
jugement de pas avoir réalisé qu'il y
avait un public qui les écoutait puis
c'est un public francophone aujourd'hui
hélène a raison c'est une image du réel
ce que je trouve moins intéressant cette
commission qui qui est pas très glamour
concernant comparativement à celle de
Gomery etc c'est que justement elle nous
montre ce qui se passe vraiment et ce
qui se passe vraiment en anglais à
Ottawa c'est que le bilinguisme c'est
l'anglais ou le traduit
c'est pas c'est pas vrai que le français
et légal de l'anglais c'est si on fait
les les petites épettes habituelles pour
donner l'impression de l'égalité de ces
deux langues là mais elle n'est pas
réelle cette égalité ça se passe en
anglais et ensuite on traduit quand on y
pense
bon très bien et c'est pas un procès
individuel sur monsieur Vignaux mais on
était mal à l'aise de certains moments
où lui-même avait de la difficulté en
anglais exprimée comme vous avez dit
Hélène des subtilités
j'ai le droit de parler français moi ici
responsables pourquoi on parle français
ok bah on lui demandera faut-il c’était
un petit sujet qu'on traîne depuis deux
trois jours mais je veux quand même le
résultat on a 7 ans on va le faire le 24
sur 5 ça fait des années moi quand
j'étais Ottawa il est on a parlé et puis
un peu à poser mais il s'est dit moi je
suis pas vrai que je dois mettre de
l'argent dans le vin la résidence
officielle du Premier ministre qu'on va
voir les images
magnifiques en fait de l'extérieur mais
qui s'écroule de l'Intérieur là je dis
la commission nationale la capitale dit
bon ben savez-vous il faut qu'on procède
on va enlever tout le système de
chauffage on va enlever l'amiante
sans égard à la décision qui sera prise
mais la personne ne veut prendre la
décision ce qu'on rénove c'est la
facture et on va voir des esquisses
c'est rendu à 28 millions je crois ou 38
millions ça c'est les esquisses qui
avaient été faits Hélène je recommence
encore vous êtes Ottawa avec vous est-ce
que on va raser la maison qui est une
très belle maison ou qu'est-ce qu'on
fait je m'abouille très souvent à la
mémoire Patrice je raserai je raserai
parce que
oui parce que la valeur patrimoniale de
cette maison elle est très très faible
elle a été contestée je pense à Laurine
Maker et ça nous coûte une fortune et
moi je trouve qu'il y a vraiment quelque
chose de chacun dans tout ça parce que
Monsieur Trudeau lorsqu'il a été élu en
2015 justement à la suite de cette
ambivalence de monsieur Harper et dit
moi j'irai pas du tout vive là et l'idée
c'était de laisser la place pour qu'on
puisse procéder aux rénovations sept ans
plus tard on a toujours pas décidé ce
qu'on va faire et là l'argent qu'on va
dépasser cet hiver c'est comme vous
l'avez dit en fait c'est pour tout vider
de sa substance cette maison il va
essentiellement ne rester que quatre
murs et bon quelques éléments
à ce prix là je trouve qu'on pourrait se
construire vraiment quelque chose de
beaucoup plus fonctionnel vous feriez
quand même une maison officielle là bien
sûr à grands coups
tout est un grand
gouvernement fédéral que ça coûte 30
millions du Canada peut vivre dans une
maison il peut recevoir des hautes
étrangers sans avoir honte que l'eau
tombe sur le front de l'invité Christian
beaucoup dans le Canada c'est un pays
qui sont pas valoir grand chose parce
qu'on n'est pas capable en fait à cause
de la démagogie justement de prévoir une
résidence officielle que de la dure pour
le premier ministre du Canada puis en
plus on dit Boulogne les statuts du
premier ministre du Canada mais que
Donald's parce que il y a eu de la
pression des autochtones
parce que le lien
se définit par l'oppression des
autochtones on dit bowling des Boulogne
la station de McDo
parce que je veux dire c'est que le
Canada c'est comme si ça manque puisque
les gens n'existe pas je vais tous les
pays il y a la maison blanche aux
États-Unis il y a le palais des idées en
France puis là juste parce qu'on veut
pas avoir l'air de dépenser de l'argent
c'est ça en fait c'est vraiment des des
considérations très démag pas très très
noble on n'est pas capable en fait
d'avoir une résidence du Premier
ministre de l'allure à Ottawa
ben moi je pense que c'est un problème
culturel qu'on a aussi incluant au
Québec on se souviendra comment même nos
premiers ministres vivaient à l'hôtel un
moment donné il y a eu toute la question
aussi de la maison sur l'avenue des
braves et ça a pris Bernard Landry en
2002 pour dire bon ben là ça suffit on
va avoir un appartement de fonction
aller difficile price deux étages le
premier ministre du Québec quel qu'il
soit votre bien installé il va pouvoir
vivre confortablement ça être dans le
luxe il va pouvoir recevoir des gens
alors imaginez raison de plus pour le
Premier ministre d'un pays du G7 quand
même au Canada et moi je suis d'accord
avec Hélène je rentrerai les boules de
doseur là dedans là on s'excuse mais il
me semble que pour certains
c'est une belle maison quand même c'est
on peut oui mais on peut on peut pas
toujours faire du neuf avec du vieux un
moment ce sont des fonds publics
bâtir une résidence officielle digne de
ce nom et qui va pouvoir accommoder les
futurs premiers ministres incluant ceux
qui ont des enfants qui ont des jeunes
familles aussi et on n'a pas avoir honte
de ça voyons donc c'est pas une
république de banane ça prend une
résidence officielle pour le premier
ministrement
mais c'est que l'avion
les libéraux avérés de Monsieur malronné
avec son avion qui avait supposément
rendu un avion de luxe luxueux que ça le
Taj Mahal or après les libéraux monsieur
chrétien aux a pu mettre un sous sur
l'avion alors c'est des vieux avions
puis ça dégoulait bon
les services de vaisselle
etc non ça prend une résidence de
fonctions et d'ailleurs
merci Hélène José Christian à très
bientôt au revoir mesdames et messieurs
c'est comme ça que ça se termine pour
nous on se revoit demain 17h une
émission tranquille demain
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici